On Monday the 23rd of May 1994, a violent storm hit the city of Perth, Western Australia. Peter Lawrence was at home with one of his daughters. He was concerned. It was getting late and his wife, Pamela Lawrence, hadn't gotten home from work yet. He called her store at 6.15pm. When he didn't get an answer, he decided he had better go down and check on her. Andrew Mallard was born on the 16th of August 1962. His parents were Roy and Grace Mallard.
1994年5月23日星期一，一场猛烈的风暴袭击了西澳大利亚州的珀斯市。彼得·劳伦斯当时正和他的一个女儿在家。他很担心，因为天色已晚，他的妻子帕梅拉·劳伦斯还没下班回家。他在下午6点15分给她的店打了电话。当无人接听时，他决定最好亲自去看看她。安德鲁·马拉德出生于1962年8月16日。他的父母是罗伊和格蕾丝·马拉德。
Andrew was born in England where his father Roy had a long career in the army. The Mallards were a hardworking, well respected and law-abiding family. Andrew also had an older sister, Jackie, who was 10 years older than him. The Mallards left England in 1967 and moved to Perth in Western Australia. Andrew had difficulty fitting into his new country. He was exceptionally tall for his age and that, combined with his English accent, was good enough to make him a target for bullies. Kids would mimic his accent, call him lots of colourful names and someone as far as to attack him physically. Andrew never felt like he belonged.
安德鲁出生在英国，他的父亲罗伊在军队中有着长期的职业生涯。马拉德一家勤劳、受人尊敬且守法。安德鲁还有一个比他大10岁的姐姐杰基。马拉德一家于1967年离开英国，搬到了西澳大利亚州的珀斯。安德鲁很难融入这个新国家。他比同龄人高出许多，再加上他的英国口音，这足以让他成为霸凌的目标。孩子们会模仿他的口音，给他起各种难听的外号，甚至有人对他进行身体攻击。安德鲁从未感到自己属于这里。
High school was even worse. Andrew being the type of kid that bullies could feel safe in hitting because they knew he wouldn't hit back. Andrew left school at 16 with no plans or career path in mind. When he turned 18, Andrew started hitting the nightclub scene. He was now a six foot, six inch tall adult. He definitely stood out in the crowd. It was the nightclub scene that introduced him to marijuana and he was soon smoking it regularly. His parents didn't approve of where Andrew was heading in life.
高中生活更糟糕。安德鲁属于那种霸凌者觉得打他很安全的孩子，因为他们知道他不会还手。安德鲁16岁时辍学，没有计划，也没有职业方向。18岁时，安德鲁开始混迹夜店。他现在是一个身高6英尺6英寸的成年人，在人群中非常显眼。正是夜店生活让他接触到了大麻，并很快开始定期吸食。他的父母并不赞同安德鲁的人生方向。
He was broke, unemployed and living at home. So he decided to do something he thought would impress them. He enlisted in the army. But he wasn't cut out for it. He never made it through basic training, instead being offered a medical discharge due to a mild sleeping disorder. Andrew returned back to Perth and got back to his old nightclubbing and dope smoking ways. He felt lost in life without a purpose. Convinced he didn't belong in Australia, he pestered his parents to buy him an airfare back to England.
他身无分文、失业且住在家里。于是他决定做一件他认为能让他们印象深刻的事：他参了军。但他并不适合军队。他没能通过基础训练，反而因为轻微的睡眠障碍被医疗退伍。安德鲁回到珀斯，又回到了他以前混夜店和吸毒的老路。他感到迷茫，生活失去了目标。他确信自己不属于澳大利亚，于是缠着父母给他买回英国的机票。
But he didn't do much good over there either. And it wasn't long before his parents were paying for an airfare to get him back home to Perth. By this stage, Andrew was on the verge of a complete breakdown. He couldn't go outside because he started suffering from extreme anxiety and panic attacks. His father Roy sent him to a psychologist who he met with every week for a few months. It really helped him start to get back on track. Andrew stopped smoking pot and he felt like he was ready to move out and face the world again. He moved into a shared accommodation place in South Perth.
但他在那边也没什么长进。没过多久，他的父母又不得不掏钱买机票让他回珀斯。到了这个阶段，安德鲁处于彻底崩溃的边缘。他不敢出门，因为他开始遭受极度的焦虑和恐慌发作。他的父亲罗伊送他去看心理医生，他每周去见一次，持续了几个月。这确实帮助他开始重回正轨。安德鲁停止了吸食大麻，他觉得准备好搬出去重新面对世界了。他搬进了南珀斯的一处合租房。
But his newfound optimism was short-lived when he was unsuccessful at a number of job interviews. When one of his housemates lit up a joint, Andrew couldn't resist his old habit. Within a few months he was broken homeless, wandering in the streets of Perth. In May 1994, Andrew met a girl named Michelle. He was instantly attracted to her. The feeling wasn't mutual, but Michelle did allow Andrew to sleep on her lounge. He couldn't believe his luck. An attractive woman was taking him in.
但他新获得的乐观情绪并没有持续多久，因为他在几次求职面试中都失败了。当他的一个室友点燃一支大麻烟时，安德鲁没能抵挡住旧习。几个月内，他就变得身无分文、无家可归，在珀斯的街头流浪。1994年5月，安德鲁遇到了一个叫米歇尔的女孩。他立刻被她吸引了。这种感觉并非双向的，但米歇尔确实允许安德鲁睡在她的沙发上。他简直不敢相信自己的运气，一位迷人的女性收留了他。
She lived in a flat just off Glide Street in Mosman Park. It took less than a week for Andrew to outstay his welcome note. Whenever Michelle started hinting it might be time for him to move on, Andrew did whatever he could to find her some marijuana. Michelle loved the smoke, and when she was stoned, the talk about him moving out stopped. Michelle didn't even know Andrew's real name. She believed Andrew was an English backpacker named Andre, who just needed somewhere to crash while he waited for some money to be transferred from England.
她住在莫斯曼公园格莱德街附近的一间公寓里。不到一周，安德鲁就招人嫌了。每当米歇尔暗示他该搬走时，安德鲁就会想尽办法为她找大麻。米歇尔喜欢抽大麻，当她吸嗨了之后，关于让他搬走的话题就停止了。米歇尔甚至不知道安德鲁的真名。她以为安德鲁是一个叫安德烈的英国背包客，只是在等待从英国转账过来的钱期间需要个落脚点。
That story didn't last long because Michelle found a copy of his resume in his backpack. But Andrew wasn't about to tell his real story. He said he was really an agent from Interpol, working to break an organised crime syndicate in Fremantle. His real name was Michael Faraday. The resume for Andrew Mallard was part of his cover. Apparently Michelle bought the story. Andrew was in the middle of a manic episode. He was spiraling out of control.
那个故事没持续多久，因为米歇尔在他的背包里发现了一份他的简历。但安德鲁并不打算说出真相。他说他其实是国际刑警组织的特工，正在努力破获弗里曼特尔的一个有组织犯罪集团。他的真名是迈克尔·法拉第。安德鲁·马拉德的简历是他掩护身份的一部分。显然，米歇尔相信了这个故事。安德鲁正处于躁狂发作期，他正在失控。
He had been coming under the attention of local police due to his ever-increasing erratic behaviour. But on the night of Sunday the 22nd of May 1994, he took things up a notch. Andrew left Michelle's place and went to a nearby unit block where a former boyfriend of Michelle's lived. He started bashing down the door of the caretaker's unit, demanding that the caretaker let him into the unit of the old boyfriend. His story? He was a drug squad detective and he had just received information that were drugs stashed in his unit. When the caretaker told Andrew she didn't have a key, he broke down his door. He was actually there to look for some items that Michelle claimed her old boyfriend had stolen from her.
由于他日益古怪的行为，他已经引起了当地警方的注意。但在1994年5月22日星期日晚上，他变本加厉了。安德鲁离开米歇尔的住处，去了附近的一个单元楼，那里住着米歇尔的前男友。他开始猛砸管理员的房门，要求管理员让他进入前男友的单元。他的借口是：他是缉毒组的侦探，刚收到消息说那个单元里藏有毒品。当管理员告诉安德鲁她没有钥匙时，他撞开了门。他其实是去寻找米歇尔声称被前男友偷走的物品。
He was basically just trying to impress her. Andrew didn't find the stolen items in his unit, but he did steal his guitar and a few jackets. But it didn't take long for the old boyfriend to put it all together, and very soon the police came looking for Andrew. He was arrested the next day, Monday the 23rd of May 1994. While he was back at the police station, he was left unattended at a desk for a period of time. So he helped himself to a police type in and a badge. He thought those would come in handy to help sell his story to Michelle and impress her even more. He was at the station until about 3.45pm when he was released.
他基本上只是想给她留下深刻印象。安德鲁没有在那个单元里找到被盗物品，但他确实偷走了他的吉他和几件夹克。但没过多久，前男友就拼凑出了真相，很快警察就来找安德鲁了。他于第二天，即1994年5月23日星期一被捕。当他在警察局时，有一段时间被独自留在桌子旁。于是他顺手拿走了一个警用打字机和一个徽章。他认为这些东西能派上用场，帮他向米歇尔兜售他的故事，让她更崇拜他。他在下午3点45分左右被释放。
He waited around for a while before eventually finding a taxi. He jumped in and instructed the driver to head to Mosman Park. He got there around 5pm. On that afternoon, Perth was hit by a massive freak storm. There were gale force winds, lightning, thunder and heavy rain. The type of storm that knocked down power poles and blacked out traffic lights. Pamela Lawrence was working in her jewellery store called Flora Metallica. It wasn't a traditional type of jewellery store.
他在附近徘徊了一会儿，最终打到了一辆出租车。他跳上车，指示司机前往莫斯曼公园。他在下午5点左右到达那里。那天下午，珀斯遭遇了一场巨大的异常风暴。狂风、闪电、雷鸣和大雨。这种风暴吹倒了电线杆，导致交通信号灯熄灭。帕梅拉·劳伦斯正在她的珠宝店“金属植物群”（Flora Metallica）工作。那不是一家传统的珠宝店。
Pam liked to dip everyday items into various metals and create her own unique style of jewellery. Her shop was located in the Glide Street shopping area in Mosman Park, near Michelle's unit. Pam was a theatre nurse before deciding on the career change. She had been lovingly married to Peter Lawrence for 23 years and they had two daughters, Amy and Katie. Pam was a friendly, bubbly person who could light up a room. Mosman Park is a mostly affluent suburb of Perth, 11km or roughly 5 miles south west of the CBD. With the Indian Ocean to the west and the Swan River to the east, it has its fair share of greened, expensive houses and well-to-do residents.
帕姆喜欢将日常用品浸入各种金属中，创造出她自己独特的珠宝风格。她的店位于莫斯曼公园的格莱德街购物区，靠近米歇尔的公寓。帕姆在决定转行前是一名手术室护士。她与彼得·劳伦斯恩爱地结婚了23年，他们有两个女儿，艾米和凯蒂。帕姆是一个友好、活泼的人，能点亮整个房间。莫斯曼公园是珀斯一个主要富裕的郊区，位于中央商务区西南11公里（约5英里）处。西临印度洋，东临天鹅河，这里有许多绿树成荫的昂贵住宅和富裕的居民。
Although it did have its share of government housing units where a lot of the residents were less desirable types, most were unemployed and addicted to drugs, turning to crime to fuel their habits. The shops around Glide Street had been the targets of several recent break-ins. Flora Metallica hadn't been broken into, but somebody had thrown a brick through the front window. The recent criminal activity led Pam to instruct her staff members that if anyone broke in or tried to rob them while they were there, just to hand over whatever they wanted. Money and material objects weren't worth getting hurt over. Pam did have a staff member working with her that day, Jackie Barsden, but she finished at 3pm.
虽然这里也有一些政府住房单元，很多居民属于不太受欢迎的类型，大多数人失业并沉迷于毒品，通过犯罪来维持他们的瘾。格莱德街周围的商店最近多次成为入室盗窃的目标。“金属植物群”没有被盗过，但有人曾向店门前的窗户扔过砖头。最近的犯罪活动导致帕姆指示她的员工，如果有人闯入或试图在他们上班时抢劫，直接交出他们想要的东西即可。金钱和物质不值得为此受伤。帕姆那天确实有一名员工和她一起工作，杰基·巴斯登，但她在下午3点就下班了。
After that, Pam was by herself. Still on that same afternoon, the 23rd of May, 13-year-old Catherine Barsden had been picked up from school by her grandmother. Catherine, the daughter of Jackie Barsden, who worked at Flora Metallica with Pam. In order to get home, Catherine's grandmother had to drive directly past the store. They actually got stopped at traffic lights directly outside. Catherine got a shock when she looked inside the shop from the car and saw a strange Caucasian man standing behind the counter. She described him as being 30-35 years old, medium-billed, a slight orange beard, 6 feet tall,
那之后，帕姆就独自一人了。还是在5月23日那天下午，13岁的凯瑟琳·巴斯登被她的祖母从学校接走。凯瑟琳是和帕姆一起在“金属植物群”工作的杰基·巴斯登的女儿。为了回家，凯瑟琳的祖母必须开车直接经过那家店。他们实际上在店外的交通灯处停了下来。凯瑟琳从车里往店里看时，看到一个陌生的白人男子站在柜台后面，这让她大吃一惊。她描述他大约30-35岁，中等身材，留着淡淡的橙色胡须，身高6英尺，
and it looked like he was wearing a bandana. Catherine kept staring at the man, and he eventually made eye contact with her, after which he immediately crouched down behind the counter. Catherine had never seen the man in the shop before. She thought it was strange and made sure to look at the clock in the car. The time was two minutes past five. She told her mum Jackie when she got home. Jackie thought it sounded strange, so she picked up the phone to call Pam to make sure she was okay.
看起来像是戴着头巾。凯瑟琳一直盯着那个男人看，他最终与她有了眼神接触，之后他立即蹲到了柜台后面。凯瑟琳以前从未在店里见过这个男人。她觉得这很奇怪，并特意看了看车里的时钟。时间是5点02分。她回家后告诉了她的妈妈杰基。杰基觉得这听起来很奇怪，于是拿起电话打给帕姆，想确认她是否平安。
But then she changed her mind, deciding it was probably nothing. Peter Lawrence was at home with one of his daughters. He was concerned that his wife, Pam, hadn't returned home from work yet. He called the store at quarter past six to see when she planned on getting home. When Pam didn't answer, he decided he had better go down and check on her. At 6.39pm, a call was made to emergency services. A woman had been attacked. An ambulance was requested to the Flora Metallica Jewelry Store at Mosman Park.
但随后她改变了主意，觉得可能没什么事。彼得·劳伦斯当时正和他的一个女儿在家。他担心妻子帕姆还没下班回家。他在6点15分给店里打了电话，想看看她打算什么时候回家。当帕姆没有接听时，他决定最好亲自去看看她。下午6点39分，有人拨打了紧急服务电话。一名女子遭到袭击。救护车被要求前往莫斯曼公园的“金属植物群”珠宝店。
Peter Lawrence had walked into the store to find Pam lying in a pool of blood with severe head wounds. Peter was covered in blood himself as he was kneeling down next to his wife, trying to help her when the ambulance and police arrived. Pam had lost leaders of blood. She was barely breathing. They put her on a stretcher and rushed her to hospital. On the way to the hospital, her breathing stopped. They performed CPR and did everything they could, but it was too late.
彼得·劳伦斯走进店里，发现帕姆躺在血泊中，头部受了重伤。当救护车和警察到达时，彼得跪在妻子身边试图帮助她，他自己也浑身是血。帕姆流了很多血，几乎没有呼吸了。他们把她抬上担架，紧急送往医院。在去医院的路上，她的呼吸停止了。他们进行了心肺复苏术，尽了一切努力，但已经太晚了。
Pam was dead on arrival. A later autopsy would reveal that Pam died as a result of her severe head wounds. The cause of the wounds was an unknown blunt force object. There were no defensive injuries. In Pam's wounds, the forensic pathologist found little specs of an unknown blue material. It was believed that that material came from the murder weapon. Detectives from the major crime squad were called in. The lead detective of the investigation was Detective Sergeant Sherville,
帕姆在到达医院时已经死亡。后来的尸检显示，帕姆死于严重的头部创伤。伤口的原因是某种未知的钝器。没有防御性伤口。在帕姆的伤口中，法医病理学家发现了少量未知的蓝色物质。人们认为该物质来自凶器。重案组的侦探被召集起来。调查的首席侦探是谢维尔警长，
assisted by Detective Caporn and a whole team of other detectives. Little was done that night in the way of a forensic investigation. The Jewelry Store was locked and guarded until the following day when a thorough examination could take place. A search was conducted to try and find the murder weapon, but they turned up nothing. Peter Lawrence pointed out that no money had been stolen from the register and no jewelry had been taken. But Pam's purse was missing. It was the next day, Tuesday the 24th of May, when police first learned about the suspicious man Catherine Barstyn had seen in the store. There was other information to consider too.
在卡彭侦探和整个侦探团队的协助下。那天晚上在法医调查方面做得很少。珠宝店被锁上并守卫着，直到第二天进行彻底检查。警方进行了搜查以试图找到凶器，但一无所获。彼得·劳伦斯指出，收银机里没有钱被偷，也没有珠宝被拿走。但帕姆的钱包不见了。第二天，即5月24日星期二，警方才第一次了解到凯瑟琳·巴斯登在店里看到的那个可疑男子。还有其他信息需要考虑。
Reports that unknown people were seen in the area acting suspiciously around the time of the murder. Other reports of some of the known local junkies hanging around too. And what about some of the undesirable characters that live in the government housing flats nearby? Or the mental health patient that lives there? Maybe it's related to the break-ins, or the brick that was thrown through the window of the store not that long ago. Many names were added to a list of possible suspects, but none of them were very solid at that stage. The list ended up containing over a hundred names. The main concern for detectives was finding out who the suspicious man in the store was that Catherine Barstyn had seen.
有报告称在谋杀发生时，有人看到不明身份的人在附近行为可疑。还有其他关于一些已知的当地瘾君子在附近游荡的报告。住在附近政府住房公寓里的那些不受欢迎的角色呢？或者住在那里的一名心理健康患者？也许这与入室盗窃有关，或者与不久前扔进店窗户的那块砖头有关。许多名字被列入嫌疑人名单，但在那个阶段，没有一个是非常确凿的。名单最终包含了100多个名字。侦探们的主要关注点是找出凯瑟琳·巴斯登在店里看到的那个可疑男子是谁。
An identity keep drawing was made up of the man based on Catherine's description and it was sent out to the media. The forensic pathologist concluded that 5pm when she saw the man fit the time frame of the attack as PM could have remained alive that long. Naturally, Peter Lawrence was a suspect in his wife's murder. But there was nothing to cast suspicion on Peter other than the fact he found his wife's body. There were no reports of violence or any other issues in the house. They were still very much in love. His daughters had no doubt that he was innocent. It was Thursday, three days after the murder, when the name of 31-year-old Andrew Mallard was first mentioned to police.
根据凯瑟琳的描述，制作了一张该男子的身份拼图，并发送给了媒体。法医病理学家得出结论，她看到该男子的5点钟符合袭击的时间框架，因为帕姆可能在那之前一直活着。自然，彼得·劳伦斯是妻子谋杀案的嫌疑人。但除了他发现了妻子的尸体外，没有任何证据让彼得受到怀疑。没有关于家中暴力或其他问题的报告。他们仍然非常相爱。他的女儿们毫不怀疑他是无辜的。那是谋杀发生三天后的星期四，31岁的安德鲁·马拉德的名字第一次被提到给警方。
As part of the investigation, police did an extensive door knock of surrounding residents. One of the people they spoke to was Michelle, the girl who had let Andrew sleep on her lounge. It was Detective Caporn who spoke with her and he learned all about Michelle's strange housemate with his weird stories and unpredictable erratic behaviour. He had been arrested for the break-in on the morning of the murder and she was sure he didn't get home until about 6.30pm on that night. Andrew wasn't home to be questioned though. He had already attended court for the break-in charge and the judge recommended that he be sent to Greyland Psychiatric Hospital for a 28-day mental health assessment. That got Detective Caporn even more interested. Caporn went to the hospital to speak to Andrew.
作为调查的一部分，警方对周围居民进行了广泛的走访。他们交谈的人之一是米歇尔，那个让安德鲁睡在沙发上的女孩。是卡彭侦探与她交谈的，他了解到了米歇尔那个奇怪的室友，以及他那些古怪的故事和不可预测的反复无常的行为。他在谋杀当天早上因入室盗窃被捕，她确信他那天晚上直到6点30分左右才回家。不过安德鲁不在家接受询问。他已经因入室盗窃指控出庭，法官建议将他送往格雷兰精神病院进行28天的心理健康评估。这让卡彭侦探更加感兴趣。卡彭去医院找安德鲁谈话。
He thought to himself that he sort of looked like the authentic picture that was made of the man Catherine Baslin saw in the store. He let Andrew know he was investigating the murder of Pamela Lawrence and asked where he was at the time of the murder. Andrew let Caporn know that after he got released from the police station, he called a taxi back to Michelle's unit in Mosman Park, getting him there around 5pm. That didn't fit with what Caporn had been told by Michelle. She said it was more like 6.30pm when he got home. Caporn also found out that Andrew used to wear bandanas, although he said he stopped wearing them several months earlier. Caporn then paid a visit to the taxi company. He found the driver who picked up Andrew. The driver didn't have any trouble remembering him because he said he was a rock star from England. He said he didn't drop him off at Michelle's unit block. It was a completely different unit block.
他心想，他看起来有点像凯瑟琳·巴斯登在店里看到的那个男人的拼图。他让安德鲁知道他正在调查帕梅拉·劳伦斯的谋杀案，并询问他在谋杀发生时在哪里。安德鲁告诉卡彭，他从警察局获释后，打了一辆出租车回到米歇尔在莫斯曼公园的单元，大约下午5点到达那里。这与卡彭从米歇尔那里得到的消息不符。她说他回家时更像是6点30分。卡彭还发现安德鲁过去常戴头巾，尽管他说几个月前就不戴了。卡彭随后拜访了出租车公司。他找到了载安德鲁的司机。司机对他记忆犹新，因为他说他是来自英国的摇滚明星。他说他没有把他送到米歇尔的单元楼，而是完全不同的一个单元楼。
Nearby, but definitely not Michelle's. Andrew told the driver he was just going in to get some friends and he would be right back. It was 5pm, but Andrew never returned. By 20 past 5, the driver realized he had done the runner on him. Caporn returned back to the hospital the next day, eager to question Andrew about this new information. He wanted to know more about this missing 90 minutes between 5pm when he got out of the taxi and 6.30pm when Michelle says he got home. It was during this second chat that Andrew came clean. He admitted running off without paying for the taxi and he says he got dropped off at that particular unit block because he knew people who he could escort to. Andrew gave numerous names of people he was with or spoke to.
就在附近，但绝对不是米歇尔的。安德鲁告诉司机他只是进去找几个朋友，马上就回来。当时是5点，但安德鲁再也没有回来。到5点20分，司机意识到他逃单了。卡彭第二天回到医院，急于就这一新信息询问安德鲁。他想更多地了解下午5点他下出租车到下午6点30分米歇尔说他回家之间缺失的90分钟。正是在第二次谈话中，安德鲁坦白了。他承认没付车费就跑了，并说他被送到那个特定的单元楼是因为他认识可以投靠的人。安德鲁提供了他与之在一起或交谈过的许多人的名字。
Detectives canvassed the unit block trying to verify his story, but they couldn't. No one remembered being with Andrew during that time. Caporn got a warrant and took Andrew's clothing for forensic testing. His right shoe tested positive for two different blood groups. One was undetermined. The second was from Blood Group B, the same blood group of Pamela Lawrence that was found in only 4% of the population. Inconsistent stories, no alibi, an admitted drug user who was displaying such bizarre behavior that it led him to being sent to a psychiatric hospital on a court order. And now there was the blood. Caporn was convinced he had his man. He briefed the rest of the detectives on the case what he had uncovered. And on Friday the 3rd of June the full result of the DNA test was revealed. The moment Caporn had been waiting for.
侦探们走访了那个单元楼试图核实他的故事，但没能做到。没有人记得在那段时间和安德鲁在一起。卡彭拿到了搜查令，取走了安德鲁的衣服进行法医鉴定。他的右鞋检测出两种不同的血型。一种未确定。第二种是B型血，这是帕梅拉·劳伦斯的血型，仅存在于4%的人口中。前后矛盾的故事，没有不在场证明，一个承认吸毒的人，表现出如此怪异的行为，以至于被法院命令送往精神病院。现在还有了血迹。卡彭确信他抓住了凶手。他向案件的其他侦探通报了他所发现的情况。6月3日星期五，DNA测试的全部结果公布了。卡彭一直在等待这一刻。
Was it Pamela's blood on Andrew's shoe? No. The initial tests were incorrect. It was actually Andrew's blood. It was the following Friday the 10th of June 94 that Andrew was released from hospital. He was diagnosed with manic depression and bipolar disorder, but he didn't have to stay there any longer. His condition was manageable so long as he agreed to keep regular appointments for treatment. Andrew had to reappear before a judge, who ruled that he was officially free to go. Detective Caporn was waiting for him in the courtroom. He approached Andrew and asked if he was prepared to go back to the station and answer a few more questions.
安德鲁鞋上的血是帕梅拉的吗？不是。最初的测试是不正确的。那实际上是安德鲁自己的血。6月10日星期五，安德鲁从医院获释。他被诊断出患有躁狂抑郁症和双相情感障碍，但他不必再待在那里了。只要他同意定期预约治疗，他的病情是可以控制的。安德鲁必须再次出庭，法官裁定他正式获释。卡彭侦探在法庭上等着他。他走近安德鲁，问他是否准备好回到警察局再回答几个问题。
If he agreed Caporn would give him his clothes and shoes back. Once they got to the police station they went straight into an interview room. They went back over Andrew's story, what he did and where he was on the day of Pamela's murder. Andrew gave the same version. He was released from the police station, caught a taxi, did the runner, tried to buy some marijuana, then returned to Michelle's flat. He also informed Caporn that he had been inside Flora Metallica in the days before the murder. He was trying to sell some of his jewellery, but he was told they weren't that type of store. Andrew wasn't under arrest. Officially he was there of his own free will. Having a chat and to get his clothes back. So his rights weren't read to him.
如果他同意，卡彭会把他的衣服和鞋子还给他。他们一到警察局就直接进了审讯室。他们重新梳理了安德鲁的故事，他在帕梅拉谋杀当天做了什么，在哪里。安德鲁给出了相同的版本。他从警察局获释，打了一辆出租车，逃了单，试图买些大麻，然后回到米歇尔的公寓。他还告诉卡彭，他在谋杀前几天曾进入过“金属植物群”。他试图卖掉他的一些珠宝，但被告知他们不是那种店。安德鲁没有被捕。正式来说，他是自愿在那里的。聊聊天，拿回他的衣服。所以没有向他宣读权利。
They started poking holes in his story about the missing 90 minutes. Andrew would give a name of someone who we thought he had spoken to in that time and the detectives would knock it down. Sorry we spoke to him and it was actually Sunday the night before the murder that you were together. How come you can't remember where you were or what you were doing Andrew? Why are you lying Andrew? What are you trying to hide Andrew? Just make it easier on yourself. Tell us the truth. What really happened? We can help you. The detectives also knew about the type in and police badge Andrew had stolen to impress Michelle. When asked about those items, he said a friend had given them to him. But they had serial numbers. The detectives knew he was lying.
他们开始在他关于缺失90分钟的故事中寻找漏洞。安德鲁会说出一个他认为在那段时间里交谈过的人的名字，侦探们就会推翻它。“抱歉，我们和他谈过了，你们在一起实际上是谋杀前一天的星期日。安德鲁，你怎么会不记得你在哪里或在做什么？安德鲁，你为什么要撒谎？安德鲁，你想隐瞒什么？让自己轻松点吧。告诉我们真相。到底发生了什么？我们可以帮你。”侦探们也知道安德鲁为了给米歇尔留下深刻印象而偷走的打字机和警察徽章。当被问及这些物品时，他说是一个朋友给他的。但它们有序列号。侦探们知道他在撒谎。
After about six or seven hours into the interview, Andrew started giving an account. Like a hypothetical account. What he believed happened. As if he was a psychic. Saying that he could get into the killer's head and read his mind. And see what happened. He started saying he thought the person responsible was evil and scared. And he just kept hitting Pam and couldn't stop. This got Caporn's attention. He read Andrew his rights. Andrew continued giving his theory. I think he was just looking to steal something. He went in through the back door. She was still in the shop locking up and saw him. He got scared. So he kept on hitting her and couldn't stop. He hit her on the head repeatedly with a wrench. Then he saw the girl in the car looking at him. He got scared and had to get out.
审讯进行了大约六七个小时后，安德鲁开始给出一个陈述。就像一个假设的陈述。他认为发生了什么。就好像他是一个通灵者。说他可以进入凶手的头脑，读懂他的心思。并看到发生了什么。他开始说他认为负责的人是邪恶和害怕的。他只是不停地打帕姆，无法停止。这引起了卡彭的注意。他向安德鲁宣读了他的权利。安德鲁继续给出他的理论。“我想他只是想偷点东西。他从后门进去。她还在店里锁门，看到了他。他害怕了。所以他不停地打她，无法停止。他用扳手反复击打她的头部。然后他看到车里的女孩在看着他。他害怕了，必须离开。”
So he moved the body, dragged her to the back door. She was making gurgling noises. So he hit her again. Then ran out. Where was the wrench the detectives asked? Andrew said the killer caught a train to North Fremantle and threw it in the ocean. Andrew was trying to please the detectives and tell them what they wanted to hear so he could get out of the interview room. Caporn took Andrew's third person account as a confession. When the detectives wanted to go back through his story again and get to the bottom of how he knew all that information if he didn't do it. Andrew lost it and started yelling and swearing, denying he was responsible, protesting his innocence. Andrew's aggression led to a physical altercation and he ended up biting Caporn. The interview was over. They charged him with assaulting a police officer but he wasn't held in custody. He was released.
“所以他移动了尸体，把她拖到后门。她发出咕噜声。所以他又打了她。然后跑了。”侦探们问扳手在哪里？安德鲁说凶手坐火车去了北弗里曼特尔，把它扔进了海里。安德鲁试图取悦侦探，告诉他们他们想听的话，这样他就能离开审讯室。卡彭把安德鲁的第三人称陈述当作了供词。当侦探们想再次梳理他的故事，并弄清楚如果不是他做的，他怎么知道所有这些信息时。安德鲁崩溃了，开始大喊大叫和咒骂，否认他负责，抗议他的清白。安德鲁的攻击性导致了身体冲突，他最终咬了卡彭。审讯结束了。他们指控他袭击警察，但他没有被拘留。他被释放了。
He never got his clothes or shoes back though. None of that first interview was recorded. The detectives made notes of what was said but they weren't signed by Andrew. While that interview was being conducted, Peter Lawrence was on the phone to Detective Sherville. He told him that he thought a 10-inch Sidcrome wrench was missing from out the back of PM's jewellery shop. The reason Andrew was allowed to go was so they could run an undercover operation on him. They didn't have enough evidence. They didn't have any evidence really. All they had was Andrew's unrecorded ramblings of a third person account of how he thought the murder happened. They needed more. So Andrew was about to meet a new friend.
但他再也没拿回他的衣服或鞋子。第一次审讯的内容都没有录音。侦探们记录了所说的话，但安德鲁没有签字。在进行那次审讯时，彼得·劳伦斯正在给谢维尔侦探打电话。他告诉他，他认为帕姆珠宝店后面少了一把10英寸的Sidcrome扳手。安德鲁被允许离开的原因是他们可以对他进行卧底行动。他们没有足够的证据。他们实际上没有任何证据。他们所拥有的只是安德鲁关于他认为谋杀是如何发生的第三人称的未录音的胡言乱语。他们需要更多。所以安德鲁即将结识一位新朋友。
They were hoping he would confess and lead the undercover officer to the murder weapon and to PM's purse. Andrew had nowhere to go. Michelle wasn't having him back and he didn't want to go back home to his parents. So he was forced to sleep in a park. It was only a few days later while Andrew was hanging in the park that he met Gary. He instantly hit it off with Gary and was impressed when he drove him around to score some dope. He was even more impressed when Gary shouted him a couple of nights in a hotel room. Gary said he was writing a book on PMler's murder and he wanted Andrew's help. Gary wanted to know all about Andrew's theory of what happened.
他们希望他能坦白，并引导卧底警官找到凶器和帕姆的钱包。安德鲁无处可去。米歇尔不让他回去，他也不想回家找父母。所以他被迫睡在公园里。仅仅几天后，当安德鲁在公园里闲逛时，他遇到了加里。他立刻和加里合得来，当他开车带他去买毒品时，他印象深刻。当加里请他在酒店住几晚时，他印象更深了。加里说他正在写一本关于帕姆·劳伦斯谋杀案的书，他需要安德鲁的帮助。加里想知道关于安德鲁对所发生事情的理论的一切。
So Andrew gave him the same story he gave to the detectives. Gary then started mentioning weapons and wanted to know what Andrew's thoughts were. Gary even brought up wrenches, specifically making mention of Sidcrome wrenches. He asked Andrew what he thought. Could that be the murder weapon? He also asked if you thought there would have been a lot of blood. What the killer would have done with his clothes, where the killer would have got the weapon and where the killer would have disposed of the weapon. Andrew was only too happy to speculate. Based on Andrew's answers, Gary's report would later read that the motive of the murder was robbery.
所以安德鲁给了他与给侦探们讲的相同的故事。加里随后开始提到武器，并想知道安德鲁的想法。加里甚至提到了扳手，特别提到了Sidcrome扳手。他问安德鲁他怎么想。那可能是凶器吗？他还问他是否认为会有很多血。凶手会怎么处理他的衣服，凶手会从哪里得到武器，凶手会把武器扔在哪里。安德鲁非常乐意推测。根据安德鲁的回答，加里的报告后来写道，谋杀的动机是抢劫。
The murder weapon was a wrench. The wrench had been thrown off a bridge into the Swan River and the killer washed the blood off his clothes using the salt water in the river. In Andrew's words, that would fuck with the forensics. Again, Andrew hadn't confessed directly, but the police believed what he was saying was information only the killer would know and he was giving his confession in some sort of speculative third-person way. Andrew wasn't well. Between their in-depth discussions about Pam's murder, he was smoking a heap of pot and his behaviour was getting more erratic. He started talking about how he had passed through several dimensions and his soul could enter different bodies.
凶器是一把扳手。扳手被从桥上扔进了天鹅河，凶手用河里的盐水洗掉了衣服上的血迹。用安德鲁的话说，那会“搞乱法医”。同样，安德鲁没有直接坦白，但警方认为他所说的是只有凶手才知道的信息，他正在以某种推测性的第三人称方式进行供述。安德鲁身体不好。在他们关于帕姆谋杀案的深入讨论之间，他抽了大量大麻，他的行为变得越来越古怪。他开始谈论他是如何穿过几个维度的，他的灵魂可以进入不同的身体。
He also mentioned that he was really a Viking warrior. That comment led Gary to encourage Andrew to participate in a makeover. Gary bought him a pair of boots, an army jacket and a kilt at a second-hand store. Then he took him to get his head partly shaved. There you go, Andrew. You look much more like a Viking warrior now. Gary started to fear for his safety, believing Andrew was a murderer and seeing his behaviour get more and more erratic. The undercover operation was called off. No admissions were made and they never got led to the murder weapon or to Pam's purse.
他还提到他其实是一名维京战士。那个评论促使加里鼓励安德鲁参加一次大改造。加里在一家二手店给他买了一双靴子、一件军用夹克和一条苏格兰短裙。然后带他去把头剃了一部分。“给你，安德鲁。你现在看起来更像一名维京战士了。”加里开始担心自己的安全，认为安德鲁是一名杀手，并看到他的行为变得越来越古怪。卧底行动被取消了。没有做出任何承认，他们也从未被引导找到凶器或帕姆的钱包。
Andrew failed to attend court for the assault police charge, so a warrant was issued for his arrest. He was arrested by Detective Brandon, who was also working on Pam's case. He was taken back to the police station and put back into the same interview room that he was in before. Detective Brandon wanted him to answer some more questions about Pam's murder. Andrew went back to his third-person theories about what he thought had happened. This time he added in a description of Pam's injuries. Andrew was able to describe them because he says he was shown a photo of them in the first interview. They handed Andrew a piece of paper.
安德鲁未能就袭击警察的指控出庭，因此发出了逮捕令。他被也在调查帕姆案件的布兰登侦探逮捕。他被带回警察局，放回了他之前所在的同一个审讯室。布兰登侦探想让他回答更多关于帕姆谋杀案的问题。安德鲁回到了他关于他认为发生了什么的第三人称理论。这一次他加入了一段对帕姆伤口的描述。安德鲁能够描述它们，因为他说他在第一次审讯中被展示了一张照片。他们递给安德鲁一张纸。
They told him to draw the wrench that he believes the killer used. Andrew did as he was told. He even wrote the word SIGCHROME on the wrench, remembering what Gary had told him. Andrew was interviewed for over 11 hours this second time round, of which only 30 minutes was recorded on video. A record of the rest of the interview was completed by the detectives making unsigned notes, just like the first interview. When the tape was turned on, they went back over the story, now asking him questions based on all the information Andrew had given them, mostly in the third person. But he also spoke in the first person at times. We brought you in this morning and we had a conversation in relation to the murder of Pam Lawrence at Mosman Park.
他们告诉他画出他认为凶手使用的扳手。安德鲁照做了。他甚至在扳手上写下了“SIGCHROME”这个词，记住了加里告诉他的话。安德鲁第二次被审讯了超过11个小时，其中只有30分钟被录像。其余审讯的记录由侦探们完成，他们做了未签名的笔记，就像第一次审讯一样。当录音带打开时，他们重新梳理了故事，现在根据安德鲁给他们的所有信息问他问题，大多是第三人称。但有时他也用第一人称说话。“我们今天早上把你带进来，我们进行了关于帕姆·劳伦斯在莫斯曼公园被谋杀的谈话。”
Do you agree with that? I do. During the course of those discussions, he told us certain things. You said that you needed money. I did. And you told us that you went in through the rear of the shop at Flora Metallica. Is that what you told us? I told you that.
“你同意吗？”“我同意。”“在这些讨论过程中，你告诉了我们某些事情。你说你需要钱。”“我说了。”“你告诉我们你从‘金属植物群’商店的后部进去。这是你告诉我们的吗？”“我告诉过你。”
I'm just going to go through that now. What you told us? We'll sort the rest out later. You told us that you went on the front on Glow Street and that you were looking back and you saw that the Flora Metallica, the door was shut. And that you thought that it was closed so it was safe to do a break. Is that what you told us? Okay. You described the steps to us and you described the rear door and the fly screen door.
“我现在要梳理一下。你告诉我们的？剩下的我们以后再处理。你告诉我们你去了格莱德街的前面，你回头看，你看到‘金属植物群’，门关着。你认为它关了，所以入室盗窃是安全的。这是你告诉我们的吗？”“好的。”“你向我们描述了台阶，你描述了后门和纱门。”
I did. Pamela Lawrence was looking the store up. Maybe she came in through the back way. The front door was a lot. And she left the key in the back door. And that's why he had an easy exit. We'll go on with what you told us earlier. Before we go into anything else.
“我描述了。”“帕梅拉·劳伦斯正在锁店。也许她从后门进来了。前门锁了。她把钥匙留在了后门。这就是为什么他有一个容易的出口。我们继续讲你之前告诉我们的。在我们进入其他任何事情之前。”
You happy with that? No problems. You told us that she became hysterical and started screaming. That's right. And that you said that you didn't mean... This is again, it's difficult because this is what you said. I didn't mean to... You said you didn't mean to cause any further injury.
“你对此满意吗？”“没问题。”“你告诉我们她变得歇斯底里，开始尖叫。”“没错。”“你说你不是故意的……这又很难，因为这是你说的。”“我不是故意的……”“你说你不是故意造成进一步伤害的。”
Because I panicked and at the time I thought I was on speed or drugs but maybe not. I think you said initially that you only meant to knock her out. That's right. You told us that she was dressed in what? A skirt or some sort of game being a woman of taste or sophistication. She would have had to be in war. Not a skirt like this but one that joins up. Okay, but the fact is that you told us all these things
“因为我惊慌失措，当时我以为我吸了安非他命或毒品，但也许没有。我想你最初说你只是想把她打晕。”“没错。”“你告诉我们她穿着什么？裙子或某种……作为一个有品位或精致的女人。她必须穿……不是这样的裙子，而是那种连在一起的。好的，但事实是你告诉了我们所有这些事情。”
and you now say that that was a complete pack of lies. That all that things that you told us. I say that is my version. My projection of the scene of the crime. We'll leave it at that. You told us you went in through the rear of the shop at Flora Metallica. I told you that. Now you said you went into the shed.
“而你现在说那完全是一派胡言。你告诉我们的所有那些事情。”“我说那是我的版本。我对犯罪现场的投射。我们就到此为止吧。你告诉我们你从‘金属植物群’商店的后部进去。”“我告诉过你。”“现在你说你进了棚子。”
Yes. You told us you got a wrench. Is that correct? A wrench from the toolbox. You said to her that you were going to rob her. This is what you told us. This is what I imagine this person would say. Okay, what I'm saying is this is what you told us.
“是的。”“你告诉我们你拿了一把扳手。正确吗？工具箱里的扳手。你对她说你要抢劫她。这是你告诉我们的。这是我想象这个人会说的。”“好的，我所说的是这是你告诉我们的。”
And you said to us you hit her how many times? I would say six to 12 at the max. The autopsy report said 12. 12 was a good answer. And on and on the questions went. Even though the detectives maintained only the killer could know this information that Andrew was giving. A lot of it was actually incorrect. His description of PM's purse and handbag were wrong.
“你告诉我们你打了她多少次？”“我会说最多6到12次。”“尸检报告说12次。”“12是一个很好的答案。”问题一个接一个。尽管侦探们坚持认为只有凶手才知道安德鲁给出的这些信息。其中很多实际上是不正确的。他对帕姆钱包和手提包的描述是错误的。
His description of the car Catherine Baslin was in was wrong. His description of what PM was wearing was wrong. His description of the back of the shop and what was stored there was also wrong. After the interview ended, Andrew still had to face court over the assault police charge. The judge sent him back to Grayland Psychiatric Hospital for another assessment. Two days later, detectives Sherville and Cape Horn met with top prosecutor John McKechnie. They presented their case to him, which was basically just Andrew's mostly third person. Confessions.
他对凯瑟琳·巴斯登所在汽车的描述是错误的。他对帕姆穿着的描述是错误的。他对商店后面以及那里存放的东西的描述也是错误的。审讯结束后，安德鲁仍需就袭击警察的指控面对法庭。法官将他送回格雷兰精神病院进行另一次评估。两天后，谢维尔和卡彭侦探会见了高级检察官约翰·麦克基尼。他们向他提交了他们的案件，这基本上只是安德鲁大多是第三人称的供词。
McKechnie said that without the video, then there definitely wasn't enough for a case. They couldn't just go with the unrecorded unsigned notes that the detectives made. But the video was the clincher. He gave the detectives the go ahead. The next day, the 19th of July, 1994, Andrew was released from hospital. Into the custody of detectives. He was charged with the murder of PML Lawrence. He wasn't sent back to the hospital.
麦克基尼说，没有录像，那么绝对没有足够的证据立案。他们不能只用侦探们做的未录音、未签名的笔记。但录像带是决定性的。他给了侦探们继续进行的许可。第二天，1994年7月19日，安德鲁从医院获释。进入侦探的拘留。他被指控谋杀帕梅拉·劳伦斯。他没有被送回医院。
He was sent to prison. The first step in the court process was a preliminary hearing to say if the prosecution had enough evidence to send the case to a trial and to see what evidence would be allowed into the trial. The judge ruled that the unsigned records of Andrew's confessions would be admissible and that the prosecution had enough evidence to proceed. A trial date was set for the 2nd of November, 1995. Andrew had no money, so he was represented by legal aid. Some might be more familiar with the case. He wasn't convinced that his public defender was up to the task, so he requested a barrister.
他被送进了监狱。法庭程序的第一个步骤是初步听证，以确定检方是否有足够的证据将案件送交审判，并查看哪些证据将被允许进入审判。法官裁定安德鲁供词的未签名记录是可以采纳的，并且检方有足够的证据继续进行。审判日期定于1995年11月2日。安德鲁没有钱，所以他由法律援助代表。有些人可能对这个案子更熟悉。他不相信他的公设辩护人能胜任这项任务，所以他要求一名大律师。
The public defender actually agreed with him and he applied for funding to get a barrister onto the case. But it was left to late. So in order to make that happen, they would need an adjournment. The public defender had no money, so he requested a barrister. The public defender actually agreed with him and he applied for funding to get a barrister onto the case. It was left to late, so in order to make that happen, they would need an adjournment. The judge didn't allow them one. The trial was to proceed as scheduled.
公设辩护人实际上同意他的看法，并申请资金聘请一名大律师处理此案。但为时已晚。因此，为了实现这一目标，他们需要休庭。公设辩护人没有钱，所以他要求一名大律师。公设辩护人实际上同意他的看法，并申请资金聘请一名大律师处理此案。为时已晚，所以为了实现这一目标，他们需要休庭。法官没有允许他们休庭。审判按计划进行。
The case was prosecuted by Ken Bates. He presented it to the jury in his opening statement as a robbery gone wrong. Andrew went to the jewellery store with the intention of breaking in, thinking no one was there. He was surprised to see PM was still working late. He panicked and bludgeoned her to death with a wrench. He stole the purse, but left before he could steal anything else due to his panicked state. During the trial, the 30-minute video was presented. Bates described it as a confession, intricate in nature, with details only the killer could know.
此案由肯·贝茨（Ken Bates）负责起诉。他在开庭陈词中向陪审团将其描述为一起抢劫未遂案。安德鲁（Andrew）去珠宝店是想入室盗窃，以为当时店里没人。他很惊讶地发现PM（受害者）还在加班。他惊慌失措，用一把扳手将她殴打致死。他偷走了钱包，但由于惊慌，在还没来得及偷走其他东西之前就离开了。庭审期间，那段30分钟的视频被作为证据提交。贝茨将其描述为一份供词，内容错综复杂，包含了只有凶手本人才知道的细节。
Although the video did start and end with the injury protesting his innocence. Caporn took the stand and it took several days for him to give his evidence. He went through the first eight hour interview, reading the notes that were written down, but not signed or recorded on video. Bates didn't call Gary as a witness. In fact, the undercover operation wasn't mentioned at the trial at all. Andrew took the stand and gave evidence. He denied everything the prosecution was alleging. At one point, he even looked at Peter Lawrence and said,
尽管视频的开头和结尾都记录了安德鲁声称自己无罪。卡彭（Caporn）出庭作证，他花了几天时间才陈述完证据。他回顾了最初那次八小时的审讯，宣读了当时记录下来的笔记，但这些笔记既没有签名，也没有录像。贝茨没有传唤加里（Gary）作为证人。事实上，卧底行动在庭审中根本没有被提及。安德鲁出庭作证并提供了证据。他否认了检方指控的一切。在某一时刻，他甚至看着彼得·劳伦斯（Peter Lawrence）说：
I did not kill your wife, Mr. Lawrence. I had nothing to do with it. He also denied saying he had killed PM with a wrench. Saying it was his theory that's what the killer used. The trial lasted for two weeks. It didn't take the jury long to reach their verdict. Guilty. He was sentenced on the 21st of December 1995. The judge had this to say.
劳伦斯先生，我没有杀你的妻子。我与此事毫无关系。他还否认曾说过自己用扳手杀害了PM。他说那只是他推测凶手可能使用的工具。庭审持续了两周。陪审团很快就达成了裁决：有罪。他于1995年12月21日被判刑。法官当时这样说道：
You showed no sign of remorse during your trial or now. At trial, you displayed confident, assertive behaviour and displayed clear evidence. You were a manipulative individual prepared to lie, cheat, steal and defraud if the need arose. You went to the shop to commit burglary, but when you realised that you would be identified, you panicked and struck PM or Lawrence repeatedly with a heavy wrench. Andrew stood up and screamed, I did not. The judge continued.
你在庭审期间以及现在都没有表现出任何悔意。在庭审中，你表现得自信、果断，并展示了清晰的证据。你是一个操纵性极强的人，如果需要，你随时准备撒谎、欺骗、偷窃和诈骗。你去那家店是为了入室盗窃，但当你意识到自己会被认出来时，你惊慌失措，用一把沉重的扳手反复击打PM或劳伦斯。安德鲁站起来尖叫道：“我没有！”法官继续说道：
The blows were delivered until you were satisfied she was dead. Your sentence will be 20 years of strict security, life imprisonment. Andrew continued to scream and protest his innocence as it was dragged away. The 20 years that was mentioned was the non-parole period. So it was possible that Andrew would never be released, especially when a big factor in parole is remorse. Andrew appealed his sentence and it was heard at the court of criminal appeal in June 1996. Three Supreme Court judges sit on the appeal.
直到你确信她已经死亡，你才停止了击打。你将被判处20年严管监禁，终身监禁。安德鲁被拖走时，仍在尖叫并抗议自己的清白。提到的20年是不得假释期。因此，安德鲁可能永远无法获释，尤其是考虑到悔罪是假释的一个重要因素。安德鲁对判决提出上诉，案件于1996年6月在刑事上诉法院审理。三名最高法院法官负责审理此案。
Andrew was now being represented by Barrister. He's Barrister attacked the confessions, labelling them unreliable because only 30 minutes was recorded out of 19 hours of total interview time. And a video camera was available in the room the entire time. He also heavily attacked the inaccuracies of Andrew's confession, the descriptions of the purse, the car Catherine was in, the shop and what PM was wearing. The fact that there was no forensic evidence, no positive ID and no murder weapon were all raised, as was the timing.
安德鲁现在由大律师代理。他的律师抨击了这些供词，称其不可靠，因为在总共19小时的审讯时间里，只有30分钟被录了下来，而房间里全程都有摄像机。他还猛烈抨击了安德鲁供词中的不准确之处，包括对钱包、凯瑟琳（Catherine）所乘车辆、商店以及PM当时穿着的描述。没有法医证据、没有确凿的身份识别、没有凶器，以及作案时间等问题都被提了出来。
It was extremely unlikely Andrew would have been able to get out of the taxi at 5 PM then run to Flora Metallica to be seen by Catherine Barsden two minutes later. The prosecution relied on what they called the 15 things in Andrew's confession that only the killer could know. But as you've heard, some of these details were given to Andrew, like the Sidcrime wrench. They couldn't even prove a wrench was the murder weapon. They certainly hadn't found the murder weapon, yet it formed one of the 15 points in Andrew's confession that only the killer could have known. The three appeal judges listened to both sides and retired to reach their verdict, which came three months later. And it was unanimous.
安德鲁极不可能在下午5点下出租车，然后跑去Flora Metallica，两分钟后就被凯瑟琳·巴斯登（Catherine Barsden）看到。检方依赖于他们所说的安德鲁供词中只有凶手才知道的15件事。但正如你所听到的，其中一些细节是别人提供给安德鲁的，比如Sidcrome扳手。他们甚至无法证明扳手就是凶器。他们当然没有找到凶器，但它却构成了安德鲁供词中只有凶手才知道的15个要点之一。三名上诉法官听取了双方的陈述，随后退庭商议裁决，三个月后裁决结果出炉，且是一致通过。
Andrew's appeal dismissed conviction upheld. Although the ruling did come with a warning to police, unrecorded confessions would no longer be allowed. But the trial result in Andrew's case wouldn't be altered. Their ruling did state there were some unsatisfactory aspects of Andrew's case, but they were happy there was no miscarriage of justice. The ruling meant that there was one court left to go, the High Court. But you couldn't just take any old case to the High Court. You first had to convince three judges that the appeal had grounds to be heard in the High Court, sort of like an application process. Generally, the High Court is only interested in severe miscarriages of justice, all matters of national importance.
安德鲁的上诉被驳回，定罪维持。尽管裁决确实对警方提出了警告，即不再允许使用未录音的供词，但安德鲁案件的审判结果不会改变。他们的裁决确实指出安德鲁的案件存在一些令人不满的地方，但他们认为不存在司法不公。这一裁决意味着只剩下一个法院可以去，那就是高等法院。但你不能随随便便把任何案件都带到高等法院。你首先必须说服三名法官，证明上诉有理由在高等法院审理，这有点像申请程序。通常，高等法院只对严重的司法不公或具有国家重要性的事项感兴趣。
Andrew's barrister failed to convince them. The case wouldn't be heard in the High Court. It was done. Andrew was imprisoned for life. Andrew struggled to cope with the ruling, demanding to take a lie detector test, even demanding to be injected with truth serum. Not knowing these weren't actually options. As time went on, he started to believe he was the victim of a big conspiracy. They must be trying to brainwash him.
安德鲁的律师没能说服他们。案件不会在高等法院审理。一切都结束了。安德鲁被判终身监禁。安德鲁难以接受这一裁决，要求进行测谎，甚至要求注射吐真剂。他不知道这些根本不是选项。随着时间的推移，他开始相信自己是一场巨大阴谋的受害者。他们一定是在试图对他进行洗脑。
The real killer was a powerful man, so Andrew was set up as a patsy. He started to believe everyone was in on it. The real murderer, the police, the lawyers, the judges, the prison guards. Everyone. The long interviews he had were actually brainwashing sessions designed to convince him he was responsible. He even went to the prison library trying to find anything he could about the murder. He even went to the prison library trying to find anything he could about brainwashing and hypnosis. Convinced this must be the answer.
真正的凶手是一个有权势的人，所以安德鲁被陷害成了替罪羊。他开始相信每个人都参与其中。真正的凶手、警察、律师、法官、狱警。所有人。他接受的长达数小时的审讯实际上是洗脑过程，旨在让他相信自己负有责任。他甚至去监狱图书馆试图寻找任何关于谋杀案的信息。他甚至去监狱图书馆试图寻找任何关于洗脑和催眠的信息，确信这就是答案。
The idea continued to grow in his head. He started to see the prison as a brainwashing facility. The lights were actually cameras, recording his every move. The live feed of which was being sent back to Detective Capel. The distress alarm in the cellar. The distress alarm in the cellar was a speaker where messages were whispered to him in his sleep. He saw the other prisoners as actors. This was their job, to come here and convince him he was in prison when really they were part of the brainwashing conspiracy.
这个想法在他的脑海中不断膨胀。他开始把监狱看作一个洗脑设施。灯光实际上是摄像头，记录着他的一举一动。实时画面被传回给卡佩尔（Capel）警探。地窖里的求救警报器是一个扬声器，在他睡觉时向他低语信息。他把其他囚犯看作演员。这就是他们的工作，来到这里让他相信自己身处监狱，而实际上他们是洗脑阴谋的一部分。
He became obsessed with the idea, refusing to speak to any other prisoners and even cutting off all visits from his family. He put up a sign in his cell. My name is Andrew Mark Mallard. I will not speak to any police or member of the justice system, prison's department or any other authority without proper legal representation. I have nothing to say. Despite his delusional state, Andrew was known as a passive, well-behaved prisoner. Andrew's parents Roy and Grace and his sister Jackie were convinced he was innocent. Roy dedicated himself to studying court transcripts, witness accounts and law books to try and find a hole in the case.
他变得对这个想法着迷，拒绝与任何其他囚犯交谈，甚至切断了与家人的所有探视。他在牢房里贴了一张告示：“我的名字是安德鲁·马克·马拉德（Andrew Mark Mallard）。在没有适当法律代理的情况下，我不会与任何警察、司法系统成员、监狱部门或任何其他当局交谈。我没什么可说的。”尽管处于妄想状态，安德鲁仍被认为是一名被动、表现良好的囚犯。安德鲁的父母罗伊（Roy）和格蕾丝（Grace）以及他的妹妹杰基（Jackie）坚信他是无辜的。罗伊致力于研究法庭记录、证人证词和法律书籍，试图找出案件中的漏洞。
He was certain the story didn't add up. Something was wrong. While obsessing over Andrew's case, Roy started to experience pain in his stomach. A trip to the doctors revealed it was cancer. And he wasn't given long to live. And he wasn't given long to live. Roy told Grace not to tell Andrew, concerned that he was already in a terrible mental state with his brainwashing conspiracy theories. He didn't want to give him something else to worry about.
他确信这个故事根本说不通。一定有什么地方不对劲。在沉迷于安德鲁案件的同时，罗伊开始感到胃痛。去医院检查后发现是癌症。而且他时日无多了。而且他时日无多了。罗伊告诉格蕾丝不要告诉安德鲁，担心他因为洗脑阴谋论已经处于糟糕的精神状态。他不想再给他增加任何烦恼。
Grace agreed. Roy died less than four weeks later. Having cut off all visits, Andrew hadn't seen his family for years. When his mother broke the news to him of his father's death, Andrew didn't believe her. He was still running with his conspiracy theory. And he believed that they had now gotten to his family. That it was a story designed to finally break him. He said,
格蕾丝同意了。不到四周后，罗伊去世了。由于切断了所有探视，安德鲁已经多年没见过家人了。当母亲向他告知父亲去世的消息时，安德鲁不相信她。他仍然坚持自己的阴谋论。他认为他们现在已经对他的家人下手了。这是一个旨在最终击垮他的故事。他说：
Don't worry, mum. I know you've been told to say this. Tell dad I know he's alright. Don't worry about me, okay? His sister couldn't convince him either. His dad was the strongest man he knew. He was in great health. No way he was dead.
别担心，妈妈。我知道他们让你这么说。告诉爸爸我知道他没事。别担心我，好吗？他的妹妹也无法说服他。他爸爸是他认识的最强壮的人。他身体状况很好。他不可能死了。
Andrew was upset they had gotten to his family, but he wouldn't let them break him. Grace Mallard never wavered from her belief that her son was innocent. She spoke to anyone who would listen about his case. One of those people was Colleen Egan, who was working for Today Tonight at the time. A current affairs news program on Channel 7. Colleen wasn't interested in the story for Today Tonight, but she was interested in it personally. What caught her attention was a letter that a well-named Barrister, Malcolm McCusker had written. Colleen used to be a court reporter, so she knew who was who in the legal circles.
安德鲁对他们对他的家人下手感到难过，但他不会让他们击垮自己。格蕾丝·马拉德从未动摇过她儿子是无辜的信念。她向任何愿意倾听的人讲述他的案件。其中一个人是科琳·伊根（Colleen Egan），她当时在第7频道的时事新闻节目《今日今晚》（Today Tonight）工作。科琳对《今日今晚》的报道不感兴趣，但她个人很感兴趣。引起她注意的是一位知名大律师马尔科姆·麦卡斯克（Malcolm McCusker）写的一封信。科琳曾经是一名法庭记者，所以她知道法律圈里谁是谁。
McCusker was well respected, and he had written that Andrew's case was very unsettling. But there was nothing that could be done unless they came up with fresh evidence that if presented to a jury, may change the outcome. That was enough to interest Colleen to take a look at the court transcripts. After which she was convinced Andrew had been given a raw deal. When Grace and Jackie went to tell Andrew that a reporter was interested in helping them, Andrew was far from impressed. Convinced this was just another part of the conspiracy. He refused to talk and said he didn't want any help. Colleen advised Grace and Jackie that they should first worry about getting Andrew's psychiatric help before they worried about fighting the case.
麦卡斯克备受尊敬，他写道安德鲁的案件非常令人不安。但除非他们能拿出新的证据，如果提交给陪审团可能会改变结果，否则无能为力。这足以引起科琳查看法庭记录的兴趣。之后，她确信安德鲁受到了不公正的对待。当格蕾丝和杰基去告诉安德鲁有一位记者有兴趣帮助他们时，安德鲁一点也不觉得印象深刻。他确信这只是阴谋的另一部分。他拒绝交谈，说他不需要任何帮助。科琳建议格蕾丝和杰基，在担心打官司之前，应该先担心为安德鲁寻求精神病治疗。
The prison was initially reluctant to force Andrew into any treatment. Sure, his behaviour was odd, but he wasn't violent, and he wasn't causing trouble. But eventually they changed their stance, and he was sent for a psychiatric assessment. It was being placed in a hospital environment that seemed to snap Andrew back to reality. He realised there was no way his fellow patients were actors, they were legitimate patients. He was in a real hospital. It suddenly became clear to Andrew, this was real. It wasn't a conspiracy, he wasn't in a brainwashing facility.
监狱最初不愿强迫安德鲁接受任何治疗。当然，他的行为很奇怪，但他并不暴力，也没有惹麻烦。但最终他们改变了立场，他被送去进行精神评估。正是被安置在医院环境中，似乎让安德鲁回到了现实。他意识到他的病友不可能是演员，他们是合法的病人。他是在一家真正的医院里。安德鲁突然清楚地意识到，这是真实的。这不是阴谋，他不在洗脑设施里。
The switch was flicked. Andrew started to come back. Gone were his delusional ramblings. Andrew wanted to cooperate with the psychiatrist and prove he was innocent. After a few months of treatment, his condition had greatly improved and he was sent back to prison. Andrew apologised to his mum and to his sister, saying that conspiracy brainwashing theory was the only way he could rationalise what had happened to him. Jackie called Colleen and told her the good news. Andrew was ready. It was a long process.
开关被拨动了。安德鲁开始回归。他那些妄想的胡言乱语消失了。安德鲁想与精神科医生合作，证明自己是无辜的。经过几个月的治疗，他的病情大为好转，被送回了监狱。安德鲁向他的母亲和妹妹道歉，说那种阴谋洗脑理论是他唯一能用来合理化发生在他身上事情的方法。杰基打电话给科琳，告诉她这个好消息。安德鲁准备好了。这是一个漫长的过程。
Colleen worked on the case for four years with the help of Andrew's barrister and many others. But they couldn't find what they needed. They hadn't uncovered any fresh evidence so there was no grounds for a new appeal. Colleen decided to approach an unlikely ally. John Quigley was a well-known lawyer who spent 25 years working with the police union, defending police officers accused of wrongdoing. He rarely lost a case. His reputation was exceptional, known as one of the best lawyers you could get. He was also a big personality who loved the law night and loved the camera.
科琳在安德鲁的律师和许多其他人的帮助下，为这个案子工作了四年。但他们找不到他们需要的东西。他们没有发现任何新的证据，所以没有理由进行新的上诉。科琳决定接触一个不太可能的盟友。约翰·奎格利（John Quigley）是一位知名律师，他花了25年时间与警察工会合作，为被指控不当行为的警官辩护。他很少输掉官司。他的声誉非常出色，被认为是你能找到的最好的律师之一。他也是一个热爱法律、热爱镜头的大人物。
Colleen knew this from her crime reporting days. But Quigley had recently quit law and had taken up politics, becoming a labour party backbencher. During the four years she had been working on the case, Colleen had changed jobs. It just so happened she was now working for a newspaper covering politics. Quigley knew everything there was to know about police procedures and practices. It's what made him such a good person to approach. But it was risky. 25 years of defending police officers had developed some solid relationships and contacts.
科琳从她做犯罪报道的日子里就知道这一点。但奎格利最近辞去了律师职务，投身政界，成为工党的后座议员。在她为这个案子工作的四年里，科琳换了工作。碰巧她现在在一家报社负责报道政治。奎格利对警察程序和做法了如指掌。这使他成为一个非常好的接触对象。但这很冒险。25年为警官辩护的经历让他建立了一些稳固的关系和人脉。
He was the only non-police officer to be given a life membership of the police union. Colleen approached him and let him know she strongly believed there was an innocent man behind bars. What better way to start a career in politics? Helping get an innocent man out of prison. Quigley didn't make any promises but he told Colleen he would have a look at the case and get back to her. It didn't take him long to find a problem. It was what happened after the first interview when Andrew was charged with assaulting police. Andrew was homeless at the time.
他是唯一一个被授予警察工会终身会员资格的非警务人员。科琳接触了他，让他知道她坚信有一个无辜的人被关在监狱里。还有什么比这更好的方式来开启政治生涯呢？帮助一个无辜的人出狱。奎格利没有做出任何承诺，但他告诉科琳他会看一看这个案子，然后再给她答复。他没花多久就发现了一个问题。那是第一次审讯后，安德鲁被指控袭击警察时发生的事情。安德鲁当时无家可归。
It was very unusual for somebody to be released on bail if they had nowhere to go. He compared this fact with the evidence of Detective Brandon, who arrested Andrew on the warrant a week later and conducted the second interview. Brandon said he was just driving around and by chance happened to see Andrew in the park. So he arrested him on the warrant. Quigley was able to put it together pretty quickly. He realized Andrew was released because they were running an undercover operation and Brandon didn't just happen to drive past him in the park.
如果一个人无处可去，被保释是非常不寻常的。他将这一事实与布兰登（Brandon）警探的证据进行了比较，后者在一周后根据逮捕令逮捕了安德鲁并进行了第二次审讯。布兰登说他只是开车到处转转，偶然在公园里看到了安德鲁。所以他根据逮捕令逮捕了他。奎格利很快就把事情拼凑起来了。他意识到安德鲁被释放是因为他们正在进行卧底行动，而布兰登并不是偶然开车经过公园。
They knew where he was the entire time. It was unusual that there was an undercover operation and it wasn't mentioned in the trial at all. The approach to Quigley had paid off. These were things that stood out to him that the others just didn't see. And Quigley assumed that there was probably more that had been hidden. He decided to meet personally with the forensic pathologist Dr Cook. Quigley asked him how it came to be that a wrench was determined to be the murder weapon. Dr Cook said he had no idea.
他们一直都知道他在哪里。不寻常的是，有一个卧底行动，但在庭审中根本没有被提及。接触奎格利得到了回报。这些是其他人没有注意到的突出问题。奎格利推测可能还有更多被隐藏的东西。他决定亲自会见法医病理学家库克（Cook）医生。奎格利问他是如何确定扳手是凶器的。库克医生说他不知道。
He told Quigley the same thing he says he told the detectives in charge of the case and the prosecutor. I find it hard to believe a wrench could have caused those injuries. Quigley showed him the sketch that Andrew had drawn of the Sidcrome wrench. Dr Cook had never seen it before. This was enough for the ball to start rolling. Quigley used his political connections to be given the prosecution file. All they had at that point were the court transcripts. It surprised them to say that tests had been done back in 1994.
他告诉奎格利他告诉负责此案的警探和检察官的同样的话：“我很难相信扳手会造成这些伤害。”奎格利向他展示了安德鲁画的Sidcrome扳手的草图。库克医生以前从未见过。这足以让事情开始运转。奎格利利用他的政治关系获得了检方档案。当时他们手里只有法庭记录。令他们惊讶的是，1994年就已经进行了测试。
To see what wounds a wrench made on a pig's head. The wounds were different to the wounds suffered by Pium. This test was never disclosed to the defence or brought up at the trial. The prosecution file also confirmed what Quigley had already worked out anyway. That there was an undercover operation. Several years had now passed since the trial. The prosecutor, Cam Bates, who was in one of his first high profile cases, was now a highly respected prosecutor with a good reputation.
看看扳手在猪头上造成了什么伤口。伤口与PM遭受的伤口不同。这个测试从未向辩方披露，也没有在庭审中提出。检方档案也证实了奎格利已经推断出的事实：确实有卧底行动。距离庭审已经过去了好几年。检察官卡姆·贝茨（Cam Bates）当时处理的是他首批高调案件之一，现在已是一位声誉卓著、备受尊敬的检察官。
John McKechnie, who was the top prosecutor in the state at the time and who gave the detectives the go ahead to charge, was now a serving Supreme Court judge. Detective Sherville and Cape Horn were now assistant police commissioners. Detective Brandon, who arrested Andrew and conducted the second interview, was now a superintendent. Not surprisingly, there was resistance to what Quigley was saying. Headlines read that Quigley was trying to get a vicious murderer off the hook on a non-disclosure technicality. Officers in charge of the case and the prosecutor's office
当时该州最高检察官、批准警探进行指控的约翰·麦基奇尼（John McKechnie），现在是一名在职最高法院法官。谢维尔（Sherville）和卡佩尔（Cape Horn）警探现在是助理警察局长。逮捕安德鲁并进行第二次审讯的布兰登警探现在是一名警司。不出所料，奎格利所说的话遭到了抵制。头条新闻称，奎格利正试图利用非披露的技术细节让一个恶毒的杀人犯逃脱惩罚。负责此案的警官和检察官办公室
maintained that the case against Andrew was strong. He had made a solid confession and a jury was convinced beyond a reasonable doubt he was the killer. But enough had now been uncovered for the case to be referred back to the court of criminal appeal. The prosecution was determined to fight the appeal. They conceded that, yes, they should have disclosed all of the information, but they maintained it was just an oversight. And it wouldn't have affected the outcome of the trial. Well-known barrister, Malcolm McCusker, whose letter got Colleen interested in the case, was now defending Andrew.
坚称针对安德鲁的案件证据确凿。他做出了坚实的供词，陪审团确信他就是凶手，排除合理怀疑。但现在已经揭露了足够多的信息，案件被移交回刑事上诉法院。检方决心反击上诉。他们承认，是的，他们应该披露所有信息，但他们坚称这只是疏忽。而且这不会影响庭审结果。那封让科琳对案件产生兴趣的信的作者、知名大律师马尔科姆·麦卡斯克，现在正在为安德鲁辩护。
And because the case was back before the court of criminal appeal and full disclosure had been made, there were a few more issues that came up. Michelle, the girl Andrew was living with at the time of the murder, was made to give several charges against him. What she was living with at the time of the murder was made to give several different statements to police. Each one slightly different, adding or taking out little details to better fit the theory that Andrew was responsible. Only her last statement was given to the defense. Catherine Barsden, the 13-year-old witness who saw the suspicious man in the shop,
由于案件回到了刑事上诉法院，并且进行了全面披露，出现了一些更多的问题。米歇尔（Michelle），安德鲁在谋杀案发生时住在一起的女孩，被迫对他提出了几项指控。她在谋杀案发生时住在一起的人被迫向警方提供了几份不同的陈述。每一份都略有不同，增加或删减了一些小细节，以更好地符合安德鲁是责任人的理论。只有她最后一份陈述被提供给了辩方。凯瑟琳·巴斯登，那个在店里看到可疑男子的13岁证人，
also made a sketch of the man she saw as soon as she got home. And she wrote a statement out herself, different to what was later presented at court. Catherine had also failed to pick Andrew out of a photo line-up, and she didn't identify him in court as the man she saw. It was found that a forensic report had also been amended. The amended version was the one supplied to the defense and presented as evidence at the trial. It was amended to remove the part that said there was no trace of salt water on Andrew's clothing. If you remember back to Andrew's theory on the crime,
一回家也画了她看到的男子的草图。她自己写了一份陈述，与后来在法庭上提交的陈述不同。凯瑟琳也没能从照片排队中认出安德鲁，她在法庭上也没有认出他就是她看到的那个男人。人们发现一份法医报告也被修改了。修改后的版本是提供给辩方并作为庭审证据提交的版本。它被修改以删除说安德鲁的衣服上没有盐水痕迹的部分。如果你还记得安德鲁对犯罪的理论，
he said that the killer washed his clothes in the salt water because it fucks with the forensics. As they were relying on his third person rinse as a confession, it didn't look good if there was no blood and no traces of salt water on his clothes. But if there was no mention of the salt water not being present, Bates could still give that theory to the jury. Andrew washed his clothes in the river, that's why there was no blood. So Andrew's defense team were arguing that evidence was withheld and statements were changed in order to make the case look a whole lot stronger than what it was. The case was heard in the court of criminal appeal before three Supreme Court judges.
他说凶手在盐水中洗了衣服，因为这会干扰法医鉴定。由于他们依赖他的第三人称洗涤作为供词，如果他的衣服上没有血迹和盐水痕迹，看起来就不太好。但如果没有提到盐水不存在，贝茨仍然可以向陪审团提出那个理论。安德鲁在河里洗了衣服，这就是为什么没有血迹。所以安德鲁的辩护团队认为，为了让案件看起来比实际情况强得多，证据被扣留，陈述被更改。案件在刑事上诉法院由三名最高法院法官审理。
On the 3rd of December 2003, they made their ruling, which was again unanimous. Appeal dismissed, conviction upheld. To keep it simple, basically they agreed with the prosecution, yes there were clearly nondisclosure issues, but no, those nondisclosures wouldn't have affected the outcome of the trial. Neither Sherville or Cape Horn were called as witnesses by the prosecution in the appeal, meaning that offence could not cross-examine them. On the 27th of October 2004, Andrew's defense team presented their case to the High Court.
2003年12月3日，他们做出了裁决，再次一致通过。上诉驳回，定罪维持。简单来说，他们基本上同意检方的观点，是的，确实存在明显的非披露问题，但不，这些非披露不会影响庭审结果。谢维尔或卡佩尔都没有被检方传唤为上诉证人，这意味着辩方无法盘问他们。2004年10月27日，安德鲁的辩护团队向高等法院提交了他们的案件。
Again, it was initially like an application process. This time they were successful. The judges granted special leave for the High Court to hear the appeal, but there was still a long road ahead. All that meant was that they got their foot in the door. It would be another year before the case was actually heard, but their day in the High Court finally came and five judges sat on the panel to hear the appeal.
同样，这最初就像一个申请程序。这一次他们成功了。法官批准了高等法院审理上诉的特别许可，但前方仍有漫长的道路。这意味着他们迈出了第一步。案件实际审理还需要一年时间，但他们在高等法院的日子终于到了，五名法官坐在小组中审理上诉。
After considering all the evidence and all the issues around the case, they reached a decision. And again, it was unanimous. Conviction quashed, a retrial was ordered. They believed there had been a miscarriage of justice. Shortly after the High Court ruling, the Corruption and Crime Commission started investigating allegations of misconduct by the lead detectives and the prosecutor.
在考虑了所有证据和案件周围的所有问题后，他们做出了决定。再次一致通过。定罪撤销，下令重审。他们认为存在司法不公。高等法院裁决后不久，腐败与犯罪委员会开始调查首席警探和检察官的不当行为指控。
The prosecution initially didn't back down, declaring they had every intention of pursuing the retrial. But their attitude changed when a judge ruled that those unrecorded and unsigned confessions wouldn't be admissible in the second trial. With that information in mind, the prosecution elected not to pursue a retrial. They took a parting shot, saying the only reason they weren't pursuing the case is because vital evidence was ruled inadmissible and that Andrew remained their prime suspect.
检方最初没有退缩，宣称他们完全打算进行重审。但当法官裁定那些未录音和未签名的供词在第二次审判中不可采信时，他们的态度改变了。考虑到这一信息，检方选择不进行重审。他们临走前放了一句狠话，说他们不追究此案的唯一原因是关键证据被裁定不可采信，安德鲁仍然是他们的头号嫌疑人。
The police agreed, saying the case would remain closed. Andrew was their man, but he had just been let off on a technicality. After being locked up for 12 years, Andrew was free. Just after Andrew's release, a blood splatter expert was in Perth testifying in an unrelated trial. He studied the photos of bloody clothing that had been taken after PM's murder. Based on those photos, he formed an opinion on who killed PM. His report wasn't good news for PM's husband, Peter Lawrence.
警方表示同意，称案件将保持结案状态。安德鲁是他们的人，但他只是因为技术细节被放走了。被关押12年后，安德鲁自由了。安德鲁获释后不久，一名血迹喷溅专家在珀斯为一起无关的审判作证。他研究了PM谋杀案后拍摄的血衣照片。根据这些照片，他形成了关于谁杀害了PM的观点。他的报告对PM的丈夫彼得·劳伦斯来说不是好消息。
Despite the police saying the case would remain closed, public pressure mounted and they were forced to reopen it and have another look. They formed a squad to re-examine every piece of evidence in the case. New technology was now available that didn't exist 12 years earlier and it was hoped that this new technology might help uncover new information. And it did. A partial palm print was fed through the computer system and it quickly produced a match. In July 1994, just seven weeks after PM's murder,
尽管警方表示案件将保持结案，但公众压力越来越大，他们被迫重新开启案件并再次查看。他们成立了一个小组，重新审查案件中的每一件证据。现在有了12年前不存在的新技术，人们希望这项新技术可能有助于发现新信息。确实如此。一个部分掌纹被输入计算机系统，很快就产生了匹配。1994年7月，在PM谋杀案发生仅七周后，
an English backpacker, Simon Rockford, was arrested for the murder of his girlfriend, Brigida Dickens. Simon had been in Perth for only six months at the time. Brigida was the local he met when he arrived to you. The cause of her death was traumatic brain injury. Simon bludgeoned her to death with a weapon he had made himself using an old weight and an old handle. Simon had spun a whole heap of lies to Brigida about who he really was and what he was doing. He gave grand tales of being rich and successful, when really he was a criminal who had overstayed his tourist visa.
一名英国背包客西蒙·罗克福德（Simon Rockford）因谋杀他的女友布里吉达·狄更斯（Brigida Dickens）而被捕。西蒙当时在珀斯仅待了六个月。布里吉达是他到达时遇到的当地人。她死亡的原因是创伤性脑损伤。西蒙用他自己用旧重物和旧把手制作的武器将她殴打致死。西蒙对布里吉达撒了一大堆谎，关于他是谁以及他在做什么。他吹嘘自己富有且成功，而实际上他是一个签证过期的罪犯。
Brigida eventually caught on to what he was doing. Brigida eventually caught on to his lies and confronted him. She threatened to report him to immigration. But Simon couldn't have that. He was the prime suspect for a stabbing murder back in England. Simon dumped her body in the boot of a car and left the murder weapon there too. The murder weapon that he had made himself, which he had painted blue. The wounds on Brigida were the same as Pam's.
布里吉达最终发现了他在做什么。布里吉达最终发现了他的谎言并与他对质。她威胁要向移民局举报他。但西蒙不能让这种情况发生。他是英国一起刺杀谋杀案的头号嫌疑人。西蒙把她的尸体扔在汽车后备箱里，也把凶器留在了那里。他自己制作的凶器，他把它漆成了蓝色。布里吉达身上的伤口和帕姆（Pam）的一样。
The unknown pieces of blue material in Pam's wounds are perfect match to the paint from Simon's murder weapon. Finally, Pam's killer was known. Andrew actually remembers Simon from prison. He thought he was strange. He would always stare at him but never say a word. Some of the prisoners even got their cases mixed up. They would say to Andrew, you're in here for that girl in the boot murder, aren't you? Andrew would reply, no, that's the other guy. I'm innocent of my crime.
帕姆伤口中未知的蓝色物质碎片与西蒙凶器上的油漆完美匹配。终于，帕姆的凶手被知道了。安德鲁确实记得监狱里的西蒙。他觉得他很奇怪。他总是盯着他看，但从不说话。一些囚犯甚至搞混了他们的案子。他们会对安德鲁说：“你是为了那个后备箱里的女孩谋杀案进来的，对吧？”安德鲁会回答：“不，那是另一个人。我的罪行我是无辜的。”
Simon made full admissions to police when he was arrested. But he kept the truth about Pam's murder to himself. Simon's interview was actually conducted by Detective Brandon. The same detective who had only just conducted Andrew's second interview a month earlier. Simon was sentenced to life in prison with a non-parole period of 15 years. Five years or less than Andrew. Brigida's autopsy was conducted by the same forensic pathologist who conducted Pam's. Some of the same detectives were involved in both cases.
西蒙在被捕时向警方做了全面供述。但他对自己杀害帕姆的事实守口如瓶。西蒙的审讯实际上是由布兰登警探进行的。同一个警探，一个月前才刚刚进行了安德鲁的第二次审讯。西蒙被判终身监禁，不得假释期为15年。比安德鲁少五年。布里吉达的尸检是由进行帕姆尸检的同一位法医病理学家进行的。一些相同的警探参与了这两个案件。
The wounds were the same. The crimes happened close together. But no one was able to link the cases at the time. Aspects of that blood splatter report naming Peter Lawrence were later criticised. Clearly it was wrong. Peter had nothing to do with his wife's murder. The real killer was now known. The corruption and crime commission later came to a conclusion as well.
伤口是一样的。犯罪发生的时间很近。但当时没有人能将这些案件联系起来。那份点名彼得·劳伦斯的血迹喷溅报告的某些方面后来受到批评。显然它是错误的。彼得与他妻子的谋杀案毫无关系。真正的凶手现在知道了。腐败与犯罪委员会后来也得出了结论。
Their reports stated, The commission is satisfied that detectives Cape Horn and Sherville, who were together involved in the process, either by persistent and repeated questioning, or by deliberately raising doubts in the witnesses' minds until they became confused, uncertain, or possibly open to suggestion, were instrumental in causing the witnesses to change their statements, by being less particular as the clothing and headwear colour
他们的报告指出：“委员会确信，卡佩尔和谢维尔警探，他们共同参与了这一过程，要么通过持续和反复的盘问，要么通过故意在证人心中制造怀疑，直到他们变得困惑、不确定，或可能容易受到暗示，在导致证人改变陈述方面起了作用，通过在服装和头饰颜色上不那么挑剔，”
so that more general descriptions could apply to Mr Mallard. The process demonstrates a pattern which the commission is satisfied cannot have been accidental or coincidence. They found that the detectives were blinded by tunnel vision. They thought the injury was the killer, so they changed aspects of the case to make it fitting better. They ruled that Sherville and Cape Horn, who if you remember were now assistant commissioners,
“以便更通用的描述可以适用于马拉德先生。”这一过程展示了一种模式，委员会确信这不可能是偶然或巧合。他们发现警探们被隧道视野蒙蔽了双眼。他们认为安德鲁就是凶手，所以他们改变了案件的某些方面，使其更合适。他们裁定谢维尔和卡佩尔，如果你还记得他们现在是助理局长，
be disciplined for misconduct, and that there were reasonable grounds for termination of their employment. Prosecutor Bates got the same recommendation. Despite the findings in the corruption and crime commission report, the police commissioner couldn't use those findings as a basis to sack the officers involved. By law, he had to conduct his own inquiry. Before that happened, Sherville resigned with full benefits.
因不当行为受到纪律处分，并且有合理的理由终止他们的雇佣关系。检察官贝茨也得到了同样的建议。尽管腐败与犯罪委员会报告中有这些发现，但警察局长不能利用这些发现作为解雇相关警官的基础。根据法律，他必须进行自己的调查。在那之前，谢维尔带着全额福利辞职了。
And Cape Horn resigned and took up another government job. Prosecutor Bates resigned and received a payout. The judges involved in the trial and the appeals process carried on with their careers. Andrew received a $3.25 million payout from the government. He left Australia and returned to England eager to find a wife and to have children. We will never know what really happened inside Flora Metallica that day, or why Simon did what he did.
卡佩尔辞职并接受了另一份政府工作。检察官贝茨辞职并获得了一笔赔偿金。参与庭审和上诉过程的法官继续他们的职业生涯。安德鲁从政府那里获得了325万美元的赔偿。他离开了澳大利亚，回到了英国，渴望找到妻子并生孩子。我们永远不会知道那天在Flora Metallica里面到底发生了什么，或者西蒙为什么要那样做。
Because when Simon Rockford was declared a prime suspect in PM's murder, he took a putty knife and hacked through his wrist and his neck, ending his life. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为当西蒙·罗克福德被宣布为PM谋杀案的头号嫌疑人时，他拿了一把油灰刀割开了自己的手腕和脖子，结束了自己的生命。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。